citizens of the reject nation
we are going to watch today she-hulk
attorney of law official mid-season
trailer john how are you i am so good
how are you i'm doing well john i'm
doing well yeah i got sent this by a ton
of people on social media oh yeah did
you hear greg the she-hulk trailer it's
a special one there's a good one in
there greg the press is greg tom go
watch it
extreme read all about it uh yeah guys
leave a like that'd be very much
appreciated i hear there's some good
stuff in here plenty of new footage we
got so much more she-hulk still coming
our way let's get to it guys
[Music]
strength is beauty beauty is strength
what makes you beautiful she-hulk by
titania oh my gosh this is the person
who legally outmaneuvered you mallory
yeah
why didn't you trademark your own
pseudonym why would i uh
did doctor strange have to trademark his
name did thor you chose two examples of
people who use their real names
[Laughter]
for wall street
it's just a thing that happened to me
you said you didn't read the name
i do admit though there are parts of it
that i enjoy
like what the amazing hair
no hangover
being able to walk home at night without
being afraid
sure
that's not the name you'd put on your
green suit put on my green tape yeah
jolly green yourself i don't know what
you call it hulking out okay good
whatever
i'm gonna find you
weird unexpected oh damn she got a super
strength
i think you're in a unique position to
do some real good jen walters can use
the law to help people when society
fails and she-hulk can help people when
the law fails
whoa this guy's really kind of dead
[Laughter]
this guy's really gotta do it for me
madison
oh
did you get a ticket for texting just
say you were texting 9-1-1 they can't
prosecute that isn't what this is and
that's not true
we got so much more daredevil i know
it's just flat out
he showed him as as matt murdock and
gave him lines and everything yeah as an
actual character it would appear i mean
those lines that they at least that they
tease us with that charlie cox having
does feel like the matt murdock from the
netflix series you know to say things
like uh jen walters can help people when
society fails them and then she-hulk can
help people when the law fails them like
yo cool he's like mentoring well he's
the perfect person to do so given his
position yeah yeah it's like that's
exactly what he does except he does it
with a secret identity whereas like
she-hulk is out there in public and i'm
excited to see more of that like kinship
it looks like they're probably gonna
fight at first as shown in the trailer
and then they're gonna actually get to
know each other where she'll probably
find to uncover his real identity or
he'll just reveal himself so that way he
can communicate the advantages of being
able to
be a hero on both sides as being
jennifer walters and being she-hulk so
that way she can't come to a full stage
of accepting this full-on identity
because that's been part of my favorite
arc with this like you're even seeing it
a lot in this trailer you know but
actually there is
a lot to being uh she-hulk that that i
am enjoying there are aspects too but do
i want to be she-hulk or i want to be
jenn walters no it's going to be a
combination of both and to see daredevil
being the thing that helps inspires is
awesome and
yeah i don't know daredevil's daredevil
show
well yeah it seems like it'll lead to a
nice uh like the way in which we've had
you know hulk turn into smart hulk into
smug hulk over time and having both of
his identities literally fused i feel
like this could make a figurative
version of that for jen where you know
part of the arc of the season i think is
probably about that of her accepting
yeah the the burden that's been thrust
upon her but also the benefits that it
can provide in the way in which it can
complement her legal career instead of
being like the death seal on it yeah
yeah well i think also with everything
that they've been going with with this
show we have mallory here who's gonna be
helping out jen
with the case against titania
and in the comics you know like they
they were they did not get along and
then eventually there was a point where
you know jen would go to to seek help
from mallory as soon as they're kind of
hopping to that like i imagine that
they'll still get some of that dialogue
where you see mallory does not entirely
approving of who jennifer walters she
hulk is
but you know women got to stick together
so you know
but i i'm excited to see more of her
because mallory is such an an important
character and it definitely seems like
that the the person who hired the
wrecking crew must have been titania
because you see titania here with
strength that can rival she-hulk she's
flat out like knocks her very very far
away so take the blood or whatever the
hell she was looking for the power that
can be found within yeah and it looks
like abomination breaking his rules
i know i'm excited about that too
because at the point of the season i
mean partly you could argue like it's
kind of a spoiler but at the same time
at the point at which we left him it's
fun to know that he will come back and
that that story is not through and that
also goes to serve the idea that it's
not just about cameos throughout the
season like some of these situations
will have aftermath and i think that's
kind of a interesting thing to explore
in a legal oriented show because so many
legal shows is pretty much like okay
case closed you're gone you're never
gonna see you again but the charm i
think of having marvel characters in
those positions is that we very much
will see them again and see
yeah what maintaining their civic
penance is like and so yeah the the
promise of more blonsky and the promise
of daredevil and and even the way this
trailer just picks up right from where
part four
left off like this is yeah this got me
really excited for the rest of the
season and two she's got her jumpsuit in
this she's got her like exactly white
like spandex and we haven't seen that
yet so i'm pretty excited just for
what's in store man i forgot that we
haven't seen that yet i know you've seen
it in the early promos and i'm like oh
yeah yeah that's the thing that's yes
yeah and hopefully more madison no
problem uh maybe we should probably get
another cameo in there she and daryl can
have a spin-off together but i also have
um
to have like abomination like going
around looks like his meditation retreat
in his abomination maybe all of his
soulmates
i don't know maybe that's uh his
soulmate's kink i don't know off the
grid but out of the country i don't know
what it is i don't know
i can't tell but it looks like he's
gonna still be going in his abomination
form even though that's not legally
allowed inhibitor man
well guys uh yeah i like the warmth that
this mid-season one brought
you put that song in there and you know
free guy
that's right
hey man you know disney using all the
stuff they own you can't blame them for
that it looks great looks great all
right guys well she-hulk
what are you most excited for other than
daredevil what are you most excited for
leave your thoughts down below subscribe
click that bell also send us
ricardo martinez
looking you up ricardo on urban
dictionary uh here we go
let's see here let's see here gosh this
is so nice i just previewed it
ricardo get this is someone that would
make a great boyfriend
because he'll listen to you and he's
always there for you and he trusts you
and loves you with all his heart and
he's loyal and he'll always remind you
how beautiful you are that's amazing and
how much he loves you and even if you
break his heart he'll still love you
never let go ricardo just always be
stuck on past love that's the thing
about latin lovers
they're so wrong about the cliches if
they'll slap their woman around and beat
them with a taco
that's not at all true and i don't know
why that's such
a cliche
that they'll roll up
with a el mariachi band
singing just awful things yeah and just
a suitcase of tacos ready to smack
anybody who comes close just not true i
don't know why that cliche exists
ricardo yeah
so and what are you doing to stop it
well what he's doing to stop it is he's
he's as this demonstrated by
urbandictionary.com
he is conquering it with love
so ricardo you keep going out there you
keep conquering the world with love and
as stated at the last sentence of this
definition you keep conquering the world
by letting the women who break your
heart just step all over you
that's love the latin way
not
full of beans
which is a cliche
very big cliche i don't know why it's a
cliche
but
men a lot of men don't drown their exes
and
and and and and a vat full of beans
i don't know how that cliche at least
ricardo doesn't but that's not the way
it is and you are clearly a
demonstration that you were not that
but i would happily die in a vat full of
beans if you if you wanted to try spy
kids was made by robert
facts
[Music]